er war vier Mal Ministerpräsident
Italiens und einer der reichsten Männer
seines Landes nun ist Silvio Berlusconi
im Alter von 86 Jahren gestorben der
rechtspopulistische Politiker
polarisierte wie kaum ein anderer
zahlreiche Affären und Skandale
begleiteten seine Karriere
es war der letzte Sieg des Silvio
belosconi das von ihm geschmiedete mit
der rechtsbündnis gewinnt die
Parlamentswahlen 2022 zwar wird Georgia
Meloni Ministerpräsidentin ihre extrem
rechte fratellit Italia stärkste Partei
doch il Cavaliere mischt wieder mit ganz
oben er prägt Italien über drei
Jahrzehnte vom Medienmogul zum
Multimillionär bis zum
Ministerpräsidenten Italiens und das
gleich viermal eine schillernde Karriere
angetreten war Bellos cloney 1994
angeblich um das korrupte Italien zu
erneuern als Politiker nutzte er
hemmungslos seine Medien macht drei
Privatsender gehörten ihm Zeitungen
Verlage ein Fußballclub
mit seiner neu gegründeten parteivorca
Italia bestimmte er Jahre lang die
Politik des Landes
mit den mächtigen zeigte sich gern
besonders mit Wladimir Putin den er auch
nach dem Angriff auf die Ukraine als
Freund bezeichnete
immer wieder geriet er mit dem Gesetz in
Konflikt die Vorwürfe Bestechung und
Betrug wegen Prostitution mit der noch
minderjährigen Ruby wurde er verurteilt
in Let's Dance aber freigesprochen
2013 wurde Berlusconi dann doch noch zu
einer Gefängnisstrafe verurteilt wegen
Steuerhinterziehung die Haft wurde
später umgewandelt in ein paar Tage
Sozialdienst wegen seines Alters
und Bellos Koni gibt nicht auf
ich bin hier ich bleibe hier ich lasse
nicht locker
[Applaus]
von seinen vielen Ankündigungen hat er
nur wenig umsetzen können im Gegenteil
Italien verharrte im Reformstau geriet
in eine Wirtschaftskrise Silvio Bellos
Tonis Anhänger glauben er habe sich für
das Land aufgeopfert seine Gegner er
habe das Land für seine Interessen
ausgenutzt was bleibt ist eine
beispiellose Karriere in Italien